let's go
next to
scipio in california scipio you're next
hey david uh do i sound okay you sound
great
okay cool uh so i'm from california so
i've been following the california
recall election yes so i wanted to ask
you a couple things sure how do you
think the california recall is going to
go like who do you think is going to
come out on top and if the worst case
scenario happens where larry elder gets
the win how do you think that would go
so i am increasingly confident
that
when it was 50 50 in terms of keep or or
remove gavin newsom
not enough people were really paying
attention yet and over the last 10 days
as many shows including ours have been
talking more and more about the recall
we've seen gavin newsom pull to almost
like a 10 point lead for keeping him
rather than removing him
so i'm cautiously optimistic that gavin
newsom is going to stay
now if he doesn't and larry elder
becomes the governor of california
i think it would be so
horrifying that i'm not even ready to to
make any predictions as to what would
happen i i think it would be untold
orders of magnitude disaster and i'm
sort of trying not to even take it that
seriously because it would be so
horrible and i'm up optimistic that
gavin newsom will stay
yeah i i feel the same way and uh my
family most of my family works in
medicine so we're all
very concerned about the possibility of
a larry elder win
just for what that would mean for masks
and vaccines in the state alone um it
would be a nightmare now are you are you
also are you as sort of cautiously
optimistic as i am that newsom will will
prevail
yeah uh it was either early this morning
late yesterday i looked at the polling
data again for the first time in a bit
and i was i breathed a sigh of relief
but i'm i'm hesitant to be that
optimistic because i don't know what's
going to happen in the next week we have
left of this thing i understand and by
the way my i'm hoping to cover the
results live on tuesday will we even get
live results on tuesday or are they not
going to be known until later in the
week
uh i'm i'm not sure okay uh from what i
understand we'll know tuesday but i
don't know if something else is going on
okay all right yeah i mean i'll plan to
cover some of it anyway and then if we
don't know exactly we don't know but
that sounds good
yeah great thanks for taking my call man
my pleasure thank you for the call let's
hope for the best there in uh in
california it could get very ugly very
very ugly and that would be
it's
i i don't even want to think about it i
don't even want to think about it
let's try bart from california it's been
a while since we've heard from bart
what's going on
bart from california you're on the air
please unmute you'll be able to chat
with me
and bart from california last chance
i'm here dave can you hear me okay
now i can sort of hear you yeah
yeah sorry about that i followed it i
was trying to figure out the new
i'm not i need to learn more about the
discord okay i really have a few
questions for you and thoughts
um one is is there is there any way to
get the message this progressive message
that you know that you're you know that
you're also supporting obviously
to the to the other side so to speak in
other words there's a lot of there's a
lot of echo chamber going on obviously
in the red states and so on
how can we combat that number one
because i think that's
part of it is there's just no other
way to get to these people and it seems
like
um and two would you be willing to do
something along those lines to help get
the message out
sorry to get to get what message out
oh uh to get your message out to you
know because right now it seems like a
lot of times we're basically in an echo
chamber of our own where we're listening
to our your aggressive message and all
that but i'm just trying to think of
ways to help get the message to uh to
republicans and those people that have
basically a fox news echo chamber so i'm
just trying to figure out ways we can
help them you know maybe some of them
anyway yeah i mean this is a much bigger
issue than you know anything i can do
obviously anytime i you know when trump
is calling i talk to them and we have a
lot of right wingers who are who are in
our audience and
but but these are bigger issues about
algorithms on social media and
confirmation bias these are really big
things that are sort of bigger than any
one show
right
anything i can do i would be glad to do
of course you know but but it just this
is like just a such a massive issue
i know it's is there any possibility of
having the show on uh fox news that
sounds funny but commercials or any kind
of thing like that is that is there
anything that we can do or is it all
controlled by fox and they'll say just
no that's interesting you're saying
could we get could we buy a commercial
for the david pakman show on fox news
correct that is correct that's
interesting that's an interesting idea i
mean listen i'm more than willing to
look into that we'd probably have to
crowdfund for i don't know what it would
cost mike lindell would know right he's
run commercials on there
i think if we if we put a commercial for
the david pakman show on fox news it
would be
fascinating let's if anybody in the
audience wants to help look into that i
would that would be great
yeah please add my name to the to the
people supporting it however i could
help okay very good yeah we'll look into
that bart
okay that's probably where the questions
i have i'm just thinking about that
particular idiom of how to reach some of
these people that because i know a lot
of them like my but even my own siblings
are support are the having it's a long
story but i have two siblings that are
problematic in this area i gotcha all
right good well i appreciate the call
bart
thanks so much david have a great love
your show thank you there's bart from
california
advertising on fox news i mean what what
could it cost could it be 50 grand for a
spot it's probably not even i don't know
uh we should look into that